wir drücken morgen mit der betonierung
die geschäftsleitung hat gerade
bestätigt dass es sich um die größte
europäische einzel betonage außerhalb
militärischer projekt gehandelt
ich weiß dass das vorhaben in den
allerbesten händen ich habe es gehört ja
du bist für das ganze verantwortlich
aber hast mit zehn stunden vorlauf
beschlossen dass du dich dabei sein gast
bei wien lockt wird gebraucht unter
anderem dringend auf einer großbaustelle
trafen wolk hat sich entschieden für
eine betrunkene nacht die konsequenzen
zu ziehen
eine kollegin hat ein kind gemacht und
das wird jetzt geboren hat angst und
braucht ihn
man macht sich auf den weg
es ist alles in ordnung hast du das mit
seinen schmerzen gesagt die kamera in
not turning back verlässt das auto nicht
ein einziges mal
der zuschauer begleitet war auf dem weg
von birmingham nach london
der hat sich für diesen schritt
entschieden obwohl er seine frau lebt
und seine zwei kinder
v angezogen
hat er die idee nicht bescheid
ich kann nicht nach hause in
spielfilmlänge sagen wir dem mann am
steuer folgen
und das funktioniert weil der regisseur
steven wright ein cleveres drehbuch
geschrieben hat
er gibt einfach eine menge zu tun ohne
dass er seine entscheidung in frage
stellt wenn der topf für das fundament
meinst du weißt nicht der richtige das
ganze nur ein zentimeter arbeitet führt
es zu rechnen
was wenn sich risse bilden
größer und größer und alles krachen
zusammen muss nur einen fehler einen
winzigen scheiß fehlt es gibt keinen
zombie angriff im film kein monster
überfall nicht einmal ein verkehrsunfall
trotzdem hält der zuschauer den atem an
ein grund dafür ist tom hardy ein
schauspieler von immenser intensität
er zeigt uns wie ein mann eine
entscheidung getroffen hat und bereit
ist dafür den preis sein spannenderes
ist im augenblick nicht zu sehen
fußabdrücke bernhard und dann muss ich
sie denken wohl es beton internet über
an